[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
9h36 emilie sa mort lundi puis cette
semaine je veux répondre à la question
de magali il m'envoie une très bonne
question ce soir est ce qu'on peut
encore dès aujourd'hui des villes
d'histoire où les bandes dessinées qui
représente de façon biaisée les
communautés autochtones autre façon un
peu passéiste donc moi je me dis oui moi
je pense qu'il ya aucun texte qu'on peut
pas lire avec un esprit critique
ça c'est certain le jeu on se mettra pas
à brûler des livres
le frame par exemple ce que je veux ce
qui fait que l'enjeu est si difficile à
discuter
c'est qu'il ya quand même un bon jeu il
ya vraiment une problématique chez les
gens de pouvoir dire le neuf mois que je
serai pas de débat stérile ou
l'empêcherait pas de lire tintin parce
que c'est des bandes dessinées de leurs
enfants c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont
et qu'ils ont aimé quand ils étaient des
enfants moi même j'ai élu astérix et
tintin et j'adorerais ces bandes
dessinées quand j'étais jeune parce que
c'était des bandes dessinées en français
elle était disponible il y avait des
séries ton s'attacher aux personnages
mais même quand j'étais une petite fille
tout de suite j'ai su qu'il y avait une
problématique de représentation j'étais
pas capable de le nommer autre regard de
définir pourquoi cette problématique
mais en lisant tintin au tibet j'ai
compris que
des choses qui était irréaliste parce
que c'est comme dans une scène où ce
qu'ils disent qu'ils jetaient les
enfants les petites fillettes dans la
rivière je me suis tu devrais peut-être
c'est de trouver la source de soi même
quand un enfant type du frein que j'aime
réforme est un peu plus
ce qui était problématique aussi quand
j'étais une petite fille par exemple
c'est justement l'absence de
contrepartie littéraire pour pouvoir
faire une comparaison
donc aujourd'hui en 2021 c'est certain
qu'on peut lire des bandes dessinées
côté crié 40 50 ans mais il faut avoir
l'utilisation de son esprit critique et
il faut se rendre compte que c'est des
textes sont écrits dans leur période et
ça représente comment les gens pensaient
aujourd'hui donc le travail qui a été
fait pour justement d invisibilité la
voix des communautés autochtones la voix
des personnes qui sont assises et est de
l'amener aujourd'hui dans une réflexion
ou est-ce que le monde apprécie la
première chose qu'ils disent et on peut
plus rien dire mais qui dit on peut plus
rien dire mais dont on n'a jamais rien
pu faire cesser de dire qui manque
aujourd'hui une contrepartie littéraire
d'élite histoire écrit par des personnes
autochtones des bandes dessinées écrits
par des personnes autochtones des romans
de la télévision de la radio il ya
manque encore énormément et un travail
qui se fait présentement vitesse grand v
tellement que des fois on te rendent pas
compte qu'ils manquent aussi de
personnes pour les écrire parce que
pendant longtemps on nous a empêchés
de croire qu'on va participer
la plateforme sociale littéraire vidéo
radio donc les personnes ne sont pas
dirigées nécessairement vers sa non pas
de développer nécessairement vers la
bande dessinée vers la littérature
france alsace donc les contreparties
dans un système qui est déjà établi
seront pas les mêmes ce qu'on peut voir
par exemple celle des contreparties qui
ont été créés mais sur des plateformes
qui nous ont été accessibles et donc
traditionnellement on s'est pas fait
refuser non plutôt que nous trouver
tellement dans les bandes dessinées
tellement dans dans les livres autant
que maintenant on en voit beaucoup
d'auteurs mais maintenant vous pouvez
aussi dans les médias sociaux vous ne
trouvez tik tok qui est beaucoup de cas
autochtones parce que c'est plate forme
n'existait pas donc elles ont été
protégés contre la fermeture qui avait
pour les communautés autochtones pour
les personnes restées alors aujourd'hui
notre enjeu ce curé des livres des
bandes dessinées cd créer du média qui
vont clairement indiqué ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui sont la relation avec les
communautés autochtones pour pouvoir
comparer avec ce qui a été fait il ya 50
ans et même quand manifestement on
repart remplacer ces vieilles bandes
dessinées les non pas faire partie de
notre histoire mais ce seront pas les
tintin dur ce sera pas les astérix qui
ont avec lui aujourd'hui qui vont au
dessus du futur et peut-être même que
ces bandes dessinées la région auront
des problématiques de non-représentation
parce qu'on prend aussi des fois de
l'absence des personnes lgbt qui tu es
on parle de l'absence des personnes qui
ont des handicaps parce que
on ne valorise pas autant que celle qui
ont pendant si longtemps habité les
bandes dessinées donc vous comprendrez
que c'est un travail qui se fait c'est
pas un travail qui doit être dans la
allen
dans l'effacement d'histoire mais il
faut comprendre que par exemple ça
existe déjà cédric sur la de l'histoire
qui c'est
parce que je le sens pas on aurait parlé
très clairement d'être propriétaires
d'esclaves et daniel nestor alors
qu'avec le temps on s'est trompé c'est
de mauvais goût et les gens qui
écrivaient les livres ont pu
tranquillement sélectionné comment il se
faisait représenter donc c'est pas une
réécriture de l'histoire on efface
l'histoire telle qu'elle est c'est que
des fois il ya comme un se rend compte
que c'était très mauvais goût et qui
aujourd'hui ben c'est pas ce qu'on veut
valoriser donc vous comprenez que c'est
un progrès un processus de processus qui
ce fait vers une écriture plus inclusive
a aussi des narrations plus inclusive
donc ça sera pas nécessairement écrit
comme un livre européen mais peut-être
des fois comme une histoire que les
premières nations sera compté déjà
entrés et les personnages qui vont
réapparaître sont des personnages de
légende alors vous comprenez le travail
est très grand faire mais c'est bon
d'avoir un esprit critique c'est bon de
pouvoir montrer aussi aux enfants
regardent comme ce que c'était fait
avant si tu tombes sur un examen qui
sait maintenant que c'était problème
c'était problématique
plutôt que d'avoir comme aujourd'hui on
a vu dans les dernières semaines un
enseignant qui se déguisait avec des
plumes ça à tête faisait des espèces de
danse par rapport et quel est le monde
rentre de suite eu un réflexe de se
soucier puce donc vous voyez il ya des
gens qui vont aussi attachée que m'en
vouloir continuer d'amener
ccc vision biaisée là mais
tranquillement ya d'autres gens qui vont
être enseignée dont on peut plus faire
ça on peut plus représenter les gens de
façon aussi détaché alors j'espère que
ça va aider ta question magali j'espère
que justement dans le progrès qu'on va
faire on va avoir de plus en plus
d'exemples d'auteur pour les enfants
pour les adolescents pour les autres on
va pouvoir proposer justin mapp aux
contreparties avec ce qui a été écrit
qui est beaucoup plus immense que ce que
nous on a proposé aujourd'hui en
contrepartie alors je souhaite une belle
semaine